we grabbed
a lot
[Music]
in 2004 I was kidnapped by the
farc one of the guerrilla groups at
that time in Colombia lasted 88 days
[Music]
oh
and
[Music]
okay
the original trip in 2003 was  as
framed in
how the desire and energy that
several biology student friends had
to explore and discover and
basically no one had come
easily I don't know how 60 years ago perhaps
and the reality base with a botanist that we
accompanied by expression and with a  local guide
after spending two or three days
checking the places where we were going to
work, some people in civilian
clothing with mules full of groceries passed by later we
understood that these people were
militiamen of the farc
at the beginning of the new days of the
assumption when the situation was not
clara I felt afraid of being in the hands
of someone who clearly did not believe
me or understand
me I believed the story that it was the truth
we are here doing doing c  Science
seeing little birds asking for plants
at that moment I was kind of afraid that
this is going to last for years or a century
or they will never want to kill us
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been very curious to
visit the former guerrillas who  We did not
kidnap from the front 41 of course at
some point they were my perpetrators and
we had a very different and
sold relationship we can go up how to march and
meet them and be able to sit down and have a
red drink and talk about life
and more friend of the days how they are
studied
names names names happy  they will make you happy and this
is your cell name or your nom de
guerre
ok we congratulate you for seeing you come no well
although in fact I really
wanted to come to see them the house
no why did they detain you because the pay at
home in the neighborhood was already that  every
tourist out there would go up to look for a loneliness bird you
never asked a man about a kidnapping
how are you how are
you today boring humanism well never
show up to co  To really talk, well,
like you,
looking at the past,
this was very necessary because we
necessarily had to do
how to get the economics.
I know that, I understand that, that is crucial if
today you have thought not
so much with your head but more with your
heart.  Like sometimes like water
is good but no one felt it was
painful because they put a person in
because they weren't used
to it.  to think that is why I
behaved very well with the people who had
to use insulin.
Come on in those days, if it had been in
your hands, Bosch, do you think that having
not retained it, we were left with some
scientists and some students, it was
incorrect, because since we are
learning now, yes,
the name  original is chile ribera
and my name is war and félix blanco
here is the chorus yes félix hagan
is a right dove that we see around
and we must  play wet
I think it is like a bird peace
well
this is the only thing I have to
present the very
simple bedroom
I am part of an ecotourism project
we are thinking of a new future there are
people who do
not agree
but there are others  that
they can be recognized
what better to forgive than to be in the
war
hello
there are three birds
there is a tile that is more more
outstanding than the others that it is as
if they had because he was below the one who
is the reason that he is badly dressed I
no longer see him
We start talking, he says if I run out at any
moment, viridis is the
scientific name of a bird. Others are
famous
to me.
This woman who was in the FARC all her
life knows a
scientific name.  Patricia de Quintero
in the ranks called me Cecilia without
mistakes
among the FARC, 15 years old, she
is very young,
we lived as if submerged
in nature, the trees for
us and  They were like ours,
we would say our house, we went out this
morning to spend a while, for example,
well, super good, downstairs,
happy, he's super interested in seeing
and learning
[Music],
we went into a trail or games that
the forest has become super beautiful, and then
for a while they were super stealthy
we heard in the distance some
super cool birds are the jumping
birds black with blue and red the head
the tail points long and we saw the birds
were relieved they are the binoculars and happy on
the other side it was also watching they
loved it  My head has already blown
[Music]
Well, look there, so I'm
three months pregnant during the
war, it was very difficult, you can imagine
one with an AK rifle, a backpack and a
baby, it's impossible, but not now that
I have the  opportunity
here goes my little seeds I do not want my
son to have to live what I lived yes and
that is what we are
betting on him with ecotourism that
the people who come here feel that they know
carry that message of peace
many of you who began to be
super young super
small guerrillas if I had taken you that
time of the decision to make one for
war much bigger more mature adults would
not have done it then or
maybe because when one  They don't
start, they think very differently, but
there is also another situation.
The young people are looking for
many young people. The vast majority of them were looking for it,
like the guerrillas, also due to a
lack of opportunities. For example, I
say it in my case, if I had been a woman I would have been
able to study and prepare.
Right now, if we had been,
we chose since we were little, my mom said, it
depends on my dad, look how fun treats her
and I don't prepare myself, yes, but if
someone has that idea, what else awaits me, God, do
you regret things
in your position,
I say in Colombia, no  there may be more
but I don't want to see more for the
war
[Music]
ah
we are going to go up towards him towards the east
towards venezuela in fact later  It is the area
where it was located in 2013,
I walked many times throughout this
finite area
where the border posts are
many times up
and this is an area that I had not
seen for 15 years, well,
until I had never arrived
For this reason, it seems very significant to me,
also, to be able to go to this glass house today,
which is the place
where I was released, very close to where they kidnapped me,
and so I have always
been very, very curious to
go simply to see this place again.
I was kidnapped where I spent
several nights it seems very nice to be able to
return
[Music]
I thought that this always happens to me when
I was little that in the house where I
lived small when I became an adult life
that is very short very small was
big here at home  come to me, well, it's
exactly the same, I already had a
memory of this metal roof being
a huge structure, this much
larger,
strange effect, an effect, an effect
like the  childhood perhaps like that
vulnerability in which
the vulnerability that was in the
kidnapping that was
like a child again here like unable
to make my decisions and without
doing things is one night do not camp here
next door I slept here next to this wall
He said that this fact was remembered as
a huge structure.
There is one thing that I
like very much
and what and what
and that something more conscious every time in
life and not only with all this
kidnapping issue is letting go letting go is
Trying to carry light luggage is not
carrying or having things in life that don't work for
you
[Music]
after having sat down
drinking various productive projects and
who are people with fears and people
who have hopes and some who got
pregnant because they had already  a process
of power if they could they wanted to put down
roots somewhere and have a normal life
the only thing that strengthens me and metal is that
we are absolutely equal we have the
rights duties as  As citizens we have
dreams we have fears we have problems
debts
happiness shared is that we are
exactly the same thing exactly the
same thing
[Music]